a second state of emergency
since april japan has announced that the
tokyo metropolitan area some 35 million
people
will face tougher restrictions to stem a
surge in covid 19 cases
numbers are 10 times higher than in the
spring starting friday in tokyo and
three neighboring prefectures
restaurants and bars will close at eight
pm and people will be asked to stay home
other businesses will have to trim their
hours companies are encouraged to have
employees
work from home schools will remain open
for now unlike the last state of
emergency
overall these new restrictions are more
relaxed than april
this noodle restaurant has been in junko
nankanese family for 26 years
now she has to close at her usual peak
time the after work crowd
we lose money if we open it costs money
even to switch the lights on
i will have to see what happens and
think about continuing to operate at
night
the restrictions will run through
february 7th but some medical experts
say
they are not severe enough to
substantially reduce the numbers
and there's growing concern that the
health care system could be overwhelmed
tokyo has borne the brunt of a third
wave of coronavirus that's hit japan
accounting for about half of all the
cases over the last several weeks
of the new cases most are people in
their twenties
with the rescheduled olympics just
months away prime minister yoshihide
suga had hoped to ride the balance of
curbing the outbreak
while stoking and ailing japanese
economy the third largest
in the world but his approval rating has
been battered by his government's covet
19 response
in order to enhance the economic economy
particularly
service sector particularly in areas
like you know traveling
um and um i would say hotels and
restaurants
uh i think the government had been
pushing a little bit too early
a little bit too much and i think people
have realized that and we're regressing
back into the
a bit of the uh our dark times when we
used to get the first wave of pandemic
so it might take a bit more than
cheerleaders at a tokyo train station to
lift the spirits
at the start of what will be a long
month for many scott heidler
al jazeera nancy snow is a professor of
public diplomacy at kyoto university of
foreign studies
and she thinks the one month
restrictions won't make a difference
they didn't move fast enough on this
one of the uh focuses
was on the economy and this was a shift
away from
virus containment to traveling
throughout japan this started a few
months ago with this go-to
travel and um that was suspended just in
the last
few weeks but i think the for the
japanese people there was a sense of
complacency
we all are wearing our masks again
that's voluntary
the social distancing though was rather
weak here there were large crowds
gathering
over new year's people going out to see
the christmas lights going to the tokyo
christmas
market mobs of people all with their
masks on
but that's not enough and i'm not sure
if
just this one month uh restriction
a so-called soft lockdown will really
make that
much of a difference i think it will get
tied to whether or not the tokyo
olympics are going to go
forward it looks like they will but it
will be
substantially different than what we
anticipated last year with the
postponement decision